dude these people thought that they
could
just join in the mob right that when the
mob started going around with torches
screaming about
bigoted racist whatever some people were
like i know if i hide in the mob
i'll be safe it's not true anymore so
there is that lady alexi mccammond
who do you hear you hear about her she's
uh
a female poc and she was going to be the
editor in chief of teen vogue oh yes i
heard about this but 10 years ago
she tweeted some disparaging things
about asians when she was 17.
well so you're saying she was an adult i
mean
17's not an adult no she was a monster
old enough i suppose
so uh basically these people thought
right right i'm kidding by the way she
was 17.
it's sweets were dumb but she lost her
job and then the company lost a
seven-figure deal
so a lot of people who are thinking i
will go along with what the mob says and
what the mob was saying at the time was
like mocking asians was okay
now they're saying it's not okay and so
all these people are now starting to get
cancelled
themselves so this is the problem with
joining
the uh the woke mob when the rules
change
because there are no real rules they
will cancel you
because you said racist things yeah
jokes whatever
like you said talked about white
supremacy and once that becomes taboo
and they realize how racist it was
they're going to cancel all the people
that were screaming white supremacy
well i'm talking specifically about uh
the the asian stuff right so we were
joking on this show that i'm double
white because i'm part asian
and so i have like you know extra
privilege you know more more than
whatever but now you can say that more
than me more than you ian okay
white male 1 but now now we have this
big thing about stop asian hate
and now all of a sudden it's like
now it's actually against the woke rules
so let me show you this thing that's
going on with this writer
and then we'll just talk about what's
going on with more cancer culture stuff
i guess because why not
ellery smith this is the the big thing
happening right now as as wokeness come
home
comes home to roost you've got
this this writer she says uh was a witch
from hell with references writer at
robot chicken producer and host
but she tweeted in 2013
who knows how old she was she said that
ho she said
she tweeted homemade pod thai and then
she said she did not put her cat into it
though
and so i get the joke i think the
problem with it that joke is that
no one accuses thai people of putting
their cats in their food
that was that was a joke about
stereotyping chinese people and chinese
restaurants in america
so it's just awful writing if if she
should be canceled it's because she's
confusing her tropes
and and her stereotypes just terrible
come on
right it would have been it would have
made more sense like oh i'm making thai
food i'm not gonna
put a seven-year-old boy in it i don't
know
don't people make isn't something people
make fun of like oh you go to thailand
to get a
kid i don't know oh
don't you have to like research what
you're talking about before you just
help
it doesn't help like it didn't work just
now so yeah
yeah you see like could you imagine a
comedian getting up there and just like
saying something that was just
made no sense and no one understood and
it wouldn't hit and you would learn your
lesson and you would adjust and you
don't really get that with twitter even
if you don't get a lot of likes or
retweets like
there's people who just they don't learn
the lesson like oh that wasn't funny or
that wasn't clever
here's the problem with this with this
woman specifically so i normally don't
like to call out the individuals by name
i try to focus on the ideas but
this is important because she tweeted on
uh
just a few days ago but week ago
remember when someone had their snl
offer revoked after using an anti-asian
slur
and so many people thought it was an
overreaction hateful language begets
violence
hateful jokes beget violence they
minimize and they dehumanize and they
allow for the normalization of terror
huh this is the perfect example of this
woman she's a writer at robot
chicken mind you like robot chicken does
offensive comedy okay they're fun
i'm fine robert chicken is fine but uh
it's it's seth green's show he's the
voice of chris on family guy
family guy is like the epitome of racism
you know right i should say
racist jokes and like stereotypical
humor and stuff
it's fine i get it it's family guy
they're jokes it's funny what she's
trying to do
is duck and keep her head down in the
mob
well now they've come for now they've
pointed out her own tweet
she could have just shut up and stayed
uninvolved but she decided to
join the mob to protect herself and it's
only made her more
more vulnerable now here's the here's
the best part she's responded twice
and she keeps making it worse
she says i posted a tasteless racist
tweet when i was 17.
it was disgusting and normalized the
exact kind of violence i meant
luckily i have been willing able to grow
in the past eight years
so i look a lot more like the girl on
the left than i do on the right
she blocked anyone from replying to this
it didn't work
people started coming after her saying
so she admits she's racist
she admits that this is who she is well
much like a person in quicksand
struggling and frantically trying to get
out and then only
sinking quicker actually i don't think
that's true about quicksand it's
probably just like from a movie you
gotta layer on your back if you're in
quicksand
is quicksand even a real thing yeah you
stepped in at once really well like up
to my thigh it was crazy and you
couldn't get out
it gets i tried pulling my leg out my
shoe came off yeah
but i wasn't very deep imagine how many
people like putting their
junk in the quicksand then you're like
that would be awesome then you're laying
down
[Laughter]
get a stick and put it behind you and
then lay back on it if you can my
friends
i would i would i would like to describe
what we're about to show you as
someone setting a fire in their own home
then getting called out for it panicking
and setting another fire in their own
home and
then burning their home down so bad so
this writer for robot chicken
after getting you know attacked for
being racist then saying yes yes
you know she knows she's racist and
getting attacked even more decided the
best thing to do
is to triple down on her admitted racism
by saying
the things i said yeah go the things i
said in 2013
and in instances both before and after
are incredibly racist and yes
violent they contributed to an ongoing
and long-standing culture of danger and
hatred
they are not excusable at any age and i
am deeply sorry
wow talk about i accidentally burned my
house down and now i'm gonna immolate
myself
that'll help yeah don't throw me a bone
i deserve it goodbye world
she she tweeted a stupid joke
in 2013 that was just a dumb joke
then eight years later
someone calls her out so she panics
calls herself
a racist then when she gets called again
she panics
and calls herself a violent racist who
is
unworthy of any of any excuse
okay dude she's a step down from her job
she needs to quit it's the only way
all of these people must quit now i'm
not racist i can't be because i'm part
asian
that's for the two of you i don't know i
don't think i'm racist
well you're white those are the rules i
make them up that's true
oh god and if you deny if you deny
you're racist that proves you're racist
that's actually part of the whole thing
they're pushing i like talking about
race as like scientifically
and like what do they call it race um oh
that's racist yeah
well it's racial but that's different
than racist yes and there's like
racism with a small r and then racism
with the big r where it's like
you might talk about race and that's
racist with the
the adjective but if you're not hating
on it then you're not being like a big r
racist no no no no no matter what you
say at any point for any reason anywhere
ian you're white you're racist period
done
that's the rule so good at this do you
like it some kind of ginger immunity
like am i no i think gingers are like
ultra white
hey whoa okay oh no aren't they isn't
there like a thing where like they're
replacing gingers and movies with poc
what they're like there's like a meme
how much more colorful can you be
like there was a meme about it where
there was like three disney movies or
something where like they had ginger
characters and then they replaced them
with like non-white characters and
people were like they're coming for the
gingers or whatever it makes me say
i think there's something about ginger
that's like they say that you're like
double white or something
super white yeah super white my favorite
kind of tuna when i get sushi
there you go oh yeah it's good it's very
super white it's great
what is it that makes it ginger like
what do you know what the chemical is
i don't know something about not having
a soul mixed yeah that's it yeah it's
just
it's great i think art aren't people
with like red hair more
um responsive to radiation but
or oh yeah you get sunburns like sun is
bad
oh yeah you can but like you can see in
the dark
right and you're crazy so that's how i'm
told yeah
okay people with blue eyes can see
better in the dark than people with
brown eyes really i can see
really good in the dark yeah yeah do you
have blue eyes
yeah and i was in dallas when the all
the black ads happen because i was
performing at a club
out there and i just got really used to
walking around the hotel in the dark i
was like this is great i know where i'm
going that's crazy
no so what can we do to encourage all of
these woke people to quit their jobs
just quit just get out you know they're
just going to do it to themselves
you know they can they can quit faster
you know what i mean they could yeah
they could
hire a person of color to replace them
that would be i think the noble thing to
do
that's weird yeah they never do that
though they really don't yeah
they talk a big game but then when it
comes time to like actually replace them
with someone
who would represent what they claim to
be for
yeah radio silence just crickets can i
say i'm gonna i'm gonna take the uh the
alternate route and say i don't want
them to quit
because it's like do you want to heal
the organ or cut the organ out
and often cutting the organ out is a is
a drastic what if the organ is woke
though
massage the organ you know the liver
it's like gangrenous
[Laughter]
i don't know i think drinking is okay
unless unless you're drinking the wrong
kind of drink like
if you're white and you drink tequila
that's like your liver gets mad like
whoa that's cultural appropriation
that's good to know woke stomach and you
eat like uh veal
it's like yes no i don't know
we we talked about this with harry's do
the woke really care about animal rights
i don't think so god who knows they just
care about like
whatever's in the moment whatever serves
them in the moment
i don't think they care about anything i
mean like yeah this woman who is
accusing herself of being a violent
racist is probably one of the
funniest like cell phones i have ever
seen it's like dude lady just shut up
setting herself up yeah like you didn't
do anything nobody cares you got people
tweeting at you it's like 30 people so
what and she just keeps making it worse
yeah it's always people say oh words are
violence it's like you've never been in
a fight
that words are worse no no no that's
exactly why they think it right
think about it like have you ever been
in a physical fight yes all right so you
understand
what violence is yeah if you've never
been in a fight the worst pain you've
ever felt is when someone called you
like a do-do-head
so here's this this this this ellery
woman you know
and she's probably growing up in some
like affluent
you know new york suburb or whatever
it's a job well i don't know probably
california writing for raw chicken
and so now the worst thing she's ever
experienced
was when you know a girl at her high
school called her fugly
and then all of a sudden she was like
i'm like hyperventilating like this pain
what am i feeling
it was called the name and then she's
like wow
is that how other people feel when
they're insulted
some people yeah so that's why she's
like it's violence to say that
meanwhile if you've ever been punched in
the face you're like i don't care what
you call me just don't punch me in the
face
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time